hey guys the peppers with a candy crush
soda saga level 476 commentary
walkthrough with tips this was a pretty
annoying level when I first played it so
impact today and figured out a couple
tips that really helped out so I'm going
to jump right in there the first room
really all you're trying to do there's
only a few colors which is nice to make
you know specials and things so really
all you're trying to do is make smart
decisions and get out of here with as
many moves left as you can you can have
so you know in the beginning whatever
comes up just go ahead and use it and
then towards the end like this is great
right here towards the end you know a
double Fisher make some fish and you can
usually get through the last couple
bears pretty quick what's interesting is
is that since this is only these three
colors this actually will come in handy
later and I didn't notice this the first
time I played it but I did notice it
today so hopefully if you're stuck on
this level to really help out let me go
ahead and make a fish here because the
strike isn't going to go up to the top
anyways so you know with the fish at
least I can match it with the striped
and basically just trying to get things
to move around so that I can get it
there we go and I'm just going to go
ahead and waste the striped candy and
match it with the fish and I think
because I don't want to move I just
don't want to lose any more moves ok
cool so the second room is is a pain and
its really congested in the middle so
the first thing you got to do is just
get rid of this column in the middle and
what I found is that through trial and
error of course is that when
you try to go down towards the bottom
it's you just don't have enough moves so
I was thinking about the fact that you
know we have these blue and green
candies here but not in the top and then
I sort of noticed that whenever we
actually bust through the top all the
pieces that fall in the middle column
that come from the top or of those two
colors okay so that is where we're going
to be able to actually make combos and
things a lot easier because we have let
you know we'd have to les couleurs so if
you watch the one of the pieces that
come down see they're all just those
three colors red orange and yellow so
what you want to do is you want to make
you know you want to just focus on this
middle part obviously we're going to
make combos and things like that outside
of it but we weren't really want to get
a nice cascade coming down through the
middle and obviously we're going to take
this and will you sprinkle shell right
after but see how that happens like
every time we get a cascade moving
downward we get brand-new brand-new
chances to catch catch specials and I
was kind of talking about something oh
yeah there we go it's kind of talking
about something else there but obviously
the the horizontal striped plus the fish
is this great combo here because it just
bypasses the need to do any of the you
know it get rid of the cakes or anything
if you hit it it's going to go straight
to the honey at the bottom and it's
going to give you it's going to hit all
of the work you know all the pieces of
honey at the bottom I think I'm probably
getting a little bit too a little bit
too technical there for no reason I was
looking for something else but as you
can see you know I get more specialist
to fall so I don't really have to you
know go too crazy here I was thinking
that I wanted to
then I wanted to drop this down to try
to get you know the comp near the combo
with the rap candy with Emma in the
color bomb but it just set off the whole
thing so again it's not a big deal
because I still have eight moves left
and because the whole nail is cleared
out if I just get cascades there and
here also you know like I should have
probably just done something else but I
wanted I got kind of greedy to want you
know Matt's get the rainbow Kimmy but
either way you know I'm done now there's
seven moves left and that's really all
there is to it I mean it you're not
going to get through the first room fast
every time and you're not going to be
able to have enough moves every time but
if you if you follow those tips there
then you will eventually get a great
cascade the specials coming down and you
get past the level before you know it so
I hope this helped i hope that if you
were stuck you'll be able to get through
it right away please like the video so
other people will find it subscribe so
that you will know when we put out new
ones and i'll be making more videos soon
so we'll see you then